I'm Gregory Clark special economics at
the University of California at Davis
but the interesting the United States is
that in the traditional associations of
names with status and rapidly being
overturned by the process of immigration
and by social mobility within the United
States so now it's a little unexpected
which are actually the high status names
and which are the low status 11 of the
thing we see is that when elegant groups
arrive in the united states there's a
pressure often to Angus eyes the name
and make it easier to pronounce the
immigrants that do that tend to end up
as lower status than the immigrants who
actually hold on to the more difficult
to pronounce original version of the
name
interestingly now even though Winfrey is
actually a traditional English name it's
a relatively low status name within the
modern United States but the new African
name such as Ejiofor and Alba now
constitute the elite surnames Billy
United States because of the process of
us immigration and because Africans who
arrived recently in the United States
tend to be a very elite group the
economy that's revealed that the Johnny
Cash song is not that the name itself is
going to make that much difference but
it's what your parents want to call you
it is actually very revealing about the
social circumstances of your family
about your lineage and consequently
about the outcomes that you'll likely to
experience of life